beauty they say
is in the eye of the beholder and what
constitutes beauty is a very subjective
idea
some people find beauty in a flower
some in animals or people
and some in scenery
having been brought up with the sandy
acres of the beach at southport in
lancashire
i found the planet coast to be a breath
of fresh air
it has variety
peculiar bay may not be the most
beautiful part of the coast
but it is essential to the welfare of
overwintering migrants
as a roosting and feeding area
winning the current blue flag award has
made ramsgate main beach a mecca for
families
as dog owners can't take their dogs on
the main beaches in high season
the beach around dalton gap is a firm
favorite
every word himself in the sea
or not some folk and dogs like to keep
their feet firmly on solid ground
the cliffs that guard the beaches are a
welcome sight to returning fishermen
i've got to admit though my phone
favorite when it comes to beaches
is botany bay
ever since the time i first discovered
it when we were scouting for locations
in my student days
it's been top of my beach list
you really can't beat the imposing
figure of the stacks
the gateway to the far beach between
these two chalk out offices
is like entering another world
more often than not this beach is
deserted and you feel that you could be
a castaway on a far distant land
it's a feeling of well solitude and it's
a welcome antidote to the hubbub of
modern daily life
as you walk along the beach on one side
of the seas garden imposing cliffs
and on the other the sea
at high tide this beach is totally cut
off and the scene nearly always reaches
the cliffs
in fine weather there's a benign feel to
the water but in reality
it's like a caged animal just waiting to
be released
and very high tides backed by the wind
can unleash that fury
this beach is really it's got its very
own castaway's cave
there are rock pools and seaweed and
beach coleman can turn up a variety of
objects
ranging from shells to the odd dogfish
head
i think the stanley coast has many fine
beaches
but for sheer wild and rugged beauty you
can't beat
this part of botany bay
you